lawmakers introduced a new bill today on  capitol hill it would streamline the  process for obtaining veterans benefits  for burn pit and other toxic exposures  more than 3 million veterans  may have come into contact with the  dangerous fumes at overseas bases  currently the va does require vets to  pay for tests  to prove any illness linked to exposure  but this bill would change that  it should not be left to veterans to dig  in their own pockets to do their own  research to hire their own lawyers  to prove that they were exposed so the  bill makes the process  easier you would only need proof a vet  was deployed in an area  where burn pits were used to qualify for  help it also does have bipartisan  support  president biden says he does want this  issue addressed no date has been set yet  for a vote but we will follow that